you guys do fantasy football oh yeah the
one Rappaport can afford hey Rappaport
look at you I one week one beat the [ __ ]
out of a Richard but I got off on the
fact that wills being very homeless he's
[ __ ] he beat the [ __ ] out of Brent
Bret Michaels still on the Brent thing
so funny he's texting me Rappaport's
texting me and Brent all day yesterday
basically asking who's winning the key
no why does Michael hey Brent again so
much he's grossed out by the swinging
stories I think he's annoyed the
parentheses
well Michaels planning a big fantasy
football party I wonder if Brent's
invited Brenda you going to Michaels oh
this is interesting
Brent were you invited to Michael
Rapaport fantasy football party he
invited the whole league are you gonna
go no no wow that's terrible
but Michael rav4 is a terrible person
Wow Wow
great you you're not gonna come to
finish you're that big of a little bit
no you're looking you're the biggest
[ __ ] you're the biggest [ __ ] on the
planet
you're the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ] on the
I'll tell you what Michael we get all
the talking can end we can bring it all
the talking to an end and we can settle
things like men any day you want you
[ __ ] no no let's get in the Octagon and
see who walks out on to their own power
oh I need I need I need nothing I need
nothing from you I don't need an
audience we can do it with nobody around
I'll get the keys to an MMA gym and you
and I'll walk in there and we'll see who
walks out under their own power you
[ __ ] farce Mar sparsh Mar I'm not
your training [ __ ] partner no I don't
have to listen to you [ __ ] football
stuff Michaels never pointed down a real
football in his life he doesn't know
what he knows about fantasy football cuz
he's never played real football fantasy
football just baiting Howard that's all
it is is betting is who's a better
degenerate gambler and he has all day to
spend on this excuse me excuse me
I fantasy better than you I fight better
than you and oh yes only way to [ __ ]
better only well
one way to only one way to find out if
we fight who fights better I'm a better
songwriter than you and you didn't write
that song you liar
do you want me to play this song Michael
oh please would you like me to do an
acapella version right now alright okay
just be patient let me warm up my voice
shitty voice Brant ugly his wife [ __ ]
[ __ ] me
France ugly he's short and ugly ah great
to the seven he thinks he's a we know
Brett is a 76 he job Brent is a 76 he's
branded he's short and vile Tyler [ __ ]
wait let me get terrible
I gotta go at Brad Michael you're an
actor you better than that
Brent sixty to seventy think we Brad
Pitt he's a bald albino good news all
over his skin it's no wonder his wife
likes to swing creepy stories from a
creepy kook when he opens his mouth I
wonder puke his vile creepy repulsive
gross
he looks like Don Rickles I love
Rapoport said he [ __ ] better than Brian
how are we gonna prove this well first
fight friend remember she's not into
[ __ ] like you okay so listen to me I
simply wanted to make you understand
that the stories are repulsive their
vile their gross youthful gun to your
head to make you listen to him idiot I'm
a paying customer I am sure you are
there's always write and shut your
[ __ ] big mouth come make me make me
boys such a good make me laugh boy I
invited you to the party you won't come
to the party why you should go to the
party [ __ ] him and his prettier wife I I
got a beautiful spread I'm gonna have a
sushi chef what's the problem the
problem is I don't like you as a human
being
oh who did you play in fantasy yesterday
will the game's not over yet that's true
how much are you losing by it's one
33 to 89 but I've got four players going
tonight that you've lost you walk you've
lost in life you lost this fantasy you
Boston look you have no room to talk
about looks go cake some more makeup on
your face that's how they get you on you
you would you say you have more freckles
on your face or liver spots I don't
really think personal against print I
don't know why did you stop with me no
you started with me long before that so
that's a [ __ ] excuse about you you're
a long walking oh gods in where grant
I'm the guest you shut your [ __ ] you
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm the guest you shut
your [ __ ] dumb phone you come try to
get me I wish you would know shut it up
I'm the guest no listen who would win in
a fight his old friend looks scary but
you ever see Rappaport he's a big gun
play ball you know but he's do you play
basketball basketball better than you a
fantasy I'm better than you in cash
about fantasy and oh yeah I'm telling
you Rappaport you saying he's not a good
fighter I bet you he is there's only one
way to find out
I'd love to see this fight